eine scheinbar altbekannte tragik philip
seymour hoffman amy winehouse oder auch
janis joplin alle ihrer drogensucht
erlegen hartnäckig dieser mythos dass
künstler vor allem im rausch großes
vollbringen dass ihnen drogen und
halluzinationen die pforten der
wahrnehmung öffnen
der blick auf große künstler eine
kulturgeschichte des rausches hieronymus
bosch soll nicht nur exzessiv mit
farbtöpfen hantiert haben sondern auch
mit halluzinogenen substanzen in seinem
überbordenden garten der lüste gedeihen
stechapfel deren gift halluzinationen
hervorrufen soll
jimi hendrix soll nach schwersten
drogentrips perfekte shows gespielt
haben
und jean paul sartre hat scheinbar sein
gesamtes werk auf amphetaminen
geschrieben
alles zufall
der neurologe boris quednow von der
universität zürich sid interessante
zusammenhänge
ich glaube dass künstler und
drogenkonsumenten zwei merkmale
gemeinsam haben einmal erhöhte neugier
die neugier 13 die kunst aber die
neugier treibt sie eben auch dazu
substanzen auszuprobieren
und das zweite ist das was die
psychologen belohnungs abhängigkeiten
hätten dass sie einfach auf zuspruch von
außen angewiesen sind und eben dieses
gefühl der belohnung der verstärkung
dass es etwas was bestimmte substanzen
eben auch stark vermitteln
sie wirken nicht alle gleich diese
teufels dinge wohin tilgt für einen
moment die angst kokain lässt das
selbstbewusstsein in die höhe schnellen
und lsd kann
farbenfroh halluzinationen bewirken der
beatles song lucy in the sky with
diamonds soll einem lsd-trip entsprungen
sein
im dokumentarfilm des ostens wird die
wirkungsgeschichte von buseck säure die
aquila mit kurz lsd beschrieben und auch
die hoffnung in den 60ern lsd könne die
kreativität steigern
viele künstler begaben sich damals in
sogenannte lsd therapie doch regisseur
martin witzes bezweifelt nach intensiver
recherche dass es einen zusammenhang zu
gesteigerter kreativität ich sehr gerne
ein großer künstler an bord calvo
gleitet jawohl das ist ein wesentlicher
bestandteil familie kunst und ich muss
eigentlich an eigentlich wieder große
husen unsere vor der moderne kunst und
photonische kunst eigentlich
schwierigkeiten kreuz finden wo das
würde bestätigen was man zuhauf findet
sind tragische fälle wie den schweizer
schriftsteller friedrich glauser seine
schwere drogensucht zerstörte sein leben
und brachte ihn lange jahre in die
psychiatrie
trotzdem schaffte er es seine romane zu
schreiben
tatsächlich haben auch krankheiten bei
künstlern das bewusstsein verändert
dostojewski litt an schweren epilepsie
anfällen und sprach von ihnen als
offenbarung höchster wahrheit und
seligkeit als gottes erkenntnis viele
seiner protagonisten erleben diese
ekstatischen augen und lewis carroll der
erfinder von alice im wunderland leta
migräneattacken
die damit verbundenen halluzinationen
sollen ihn zu den seltsamen größen und
formen veränderungen angeregt haben
in ganz seltenen fällen kann man eine
klare wechselwirkung von drogenrausch
und kreativität erkennen wie bei
williams daraus sein roman naked lunch
ist ein einziger trip und sammelsurium
seine halluzinationen
es ist bloß eigene geschichte bestätigt
all das nur den mythos
ich fürchte dass es auf diese frage
keine pauschale antwort gibt sondern das
ist vielleicht leute gibt die ihre
drogenerfahrungen tatsächlich in eine
erhöhte kreativität umsetzen konnten
aber ich glaube sie mal aus einem
schlechten künstler mit drogen keinen
besseren
wie bei allen mythen schwingt wohl auch
hier ein fünkchen wahrheit mit der rest
ist wohl gepflegtes fantastisches
geheimnis